Hello, and welcome back to Rawkode
Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan. And today, we're
gonna be continuing our complete guide to Parca.
Today's tutorial
we'll be configuring the scrape config to use
Kubernetes service discovery.
But first,
why?
Well, so far in this course, we have
deployed to Parca server and seen that it
doesn't really do much by default. It's a
database that needs data.
To provide that data, we've been using the
Parca agent,
which is fantastic.
You deploy the Parca agent to your cluster.
It runs as a daemon set, discovers the
processes on the nodes using eBPF
and gets you loads of amazing profile information
to get started with no with little to
no effort.
However,
sometimes
you may want to provide your own p
professor information.
Some languages like Node. Js and Go have
fantastic support for stuff and an even more
information from the runtimes themselves.
So what if we want to consume that?
Well, we can configure the Parca server
with scrape configs, scrape targets,
much like Prometheus itself.
And in fact, it allows us to use
the service discovery modules from the Prometheus package,
and the configuration is identical.
So in today's video, we're going to change
the config of Parca, add a scrape config
using Kubernetes service discovery
to filter for annotations that we just saved.
I have a workload deployed to my cluster,
which is influx d b two. I'm using
influx d b two because it ships by
default with a p professor endpoint.
We're going to configure Parca to scrape that
endpoint and give us all the information.
So let's take a look.
Okay. So let's set the scene. First,
we have a default namespace,
box d b two.
We also have Parca namespace.
Parca deployed.
Please note, there is no Parca agent. Meaning,
currently, Parca has no data whatsoever.
This is the default install of InvoiceDB two.
Nothing has been tweaked. And this is the
default install of Parca. Nothing has been tweaked.
We are running a port forward and another
tab to the Parca UI or the Parca
server.
So we can pop open
and hit refresh a whole bunch of times
and see that nothing has changed. The Parca
server has not received any data.
And if we come to targets,
there are no targets available.
Our Parca has nothing to scrape, and nothing
has been written via the push model and
the agent.
So how do we get started?
Well, we can modify the Parca config map.
This provides everything that we need to modify
and provide our own scrape target configuration.
Personally,
I've already prepared a config map for us
to take a look at.
It's a little bit bigger.
And we'll see here, this is what the
default Parca conflict map looks like. It just
configures the bucket, in this case, file system
and a directory of where to store its
data.
We can confirm this from the command line
where we can see get config map Parca
dash o channel.
You will see the default configuration.
But we can change this. Right? So we
can say, let's add a script config.
Now remember, this is just Prometheus
format for configuration. If you have configured Prometheus
before to do service discovery and configure dynamic
script targets, it's very much the same for
Parca.
We can give our job a name here.
We're calling it PPROF endpoints,
where we're going to rely on the Kubernetes
service discovery configuration.
And here, I'm asking it to find all
pods.
Next, we can define the relabel config.
This will allow us to keep or drop
different targets based on attributes within the target
itself,
the pod.
So here, we can see that we only
want to keep
discovered pods as a target if it has
a Parca.
Dev slash profile annotation.
You can see here we're asking for the
Kubernetes metadata on the pod and annotations.
This name here is just a
simplified version of parka dot dev slash profile
where dots and slashes are replaced with underscores.
And we're just going to say
keep.
Now we also need to handle where the
p professor information is available on different paths
and on different ports.
So here, we can say that we expect
an annotation of parca dot dev slash path.
This
will be our metrics path.
Likewise, we can see the Parca dot dev
slash port,
and we can actually
construct or compose
the address from all previous information.
And that's it.
However,
we said something a few moments ago that's
worth good over again.
The Kubernetes service discovery config
will currently try to find all pods.
The all pods is subjective and that do
you want to bind it to a namespace
or be cluster wide.
Regardless,
Parca needs
some permissions
in order to be able to do so.
As such, I've chosen to define a cluster
role,
which gives it the ability to watch, list,
and get all pods
across the entire cluster.
This is not a video on Kubernetes RBAG.
So if you want to do this differently,
feel free.
I'm just keeping things simple and easy for
today's demonstration.
Once we have the cluster role, we must
bind it to the Parca servers account inside
of the Parca namespace.
Simple.
So we can come back to the command
line
where we can run goof control and play
to update the contact map and to apply
the cluster role and cluster role binding.
Now if we can come back to Parca
server,
wherever we have refresh, we should see the
new job for our script configuration.
Like so.
Okay. So we've refreshed and nothing has happened.
But of course, that's because we need to
do one more thing.
That is we need to add our annotations
to the influx DB workload.
So let's jump back over to our terminal
where we can go to control edit
stateful set influx DB two.
We can jump down to the template
for all the pods
where we can add our annotations.
You can say parka.dev
slash profile.
We can just set that to true.
We also need to set our parka.dev
slash path to be our path to the
p professor endpoint
on Parca.
Dev port
to eight zero eight six.
Now on InfluxDB,
the p professor endpoint is available at debug
p professor.
So
now we can hit save
and our Parker server
will reach out to the k the Kubernetes
API server,
get information on the pods, find our annotations
and update
our target list.
So let's hit refresh.
And there we go.
We can now see the pod IP for
our influx DB pod. Debug p professor based
path and it is now detected
allocations, block, go routines, mutex,
and point.
These are now
good
or they all will be good in time.
This now means we can head over to
profiles
where we have all the profiles being script.
So let's just do go routines being created.
Filter on our job, which is just gonna
be p professor endpoints.
Let go.
Now we can see our new profile and
information being collected from the influx d endpoint
using annotations
on the workload
with dynamic scrape config using the Kubernetes service
discovery config.
Awesome.
Okay. So the takeaway here is, first, if
you can use the Parca agent and you
get everything you need, just use the Parca
agent.
However,
if you have Google applications,
Node. Js applications, other environments where you need
to rely or want to consume more information
using language specific integrations,
they're very easy to configure.
Within a Kubernetes environment, you just need to
give your Parca server
the right access to query nodes, services, endpoints,
or pods depending on your Prometheus scrape configuration.
From there, you can configure your workloads with
the appropriate annotations,
and the job is done.
So go forth.
Profile everything under Kubernetes with Parca.
Go have some fun.